on parle de la semaine politique Samia
d'abord on va parler de ce qui s'est
passé hier puisque c'était la première
séance de question de gouvernement de
cette année 2024 première séance de
Gabriel Attal Premier ministre oui hein
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement c'est un exercice auquel
l'exécutif doit se plier chaque semaine
répondre aux questions des
parlementaires sur l'actualité sur la
politique qu'il mène hier c'était donc
une première pour le tout nouveau
gouvernement à tal et c'était beaucoup
plus apaisé qu'à l'Assemblée nationale
où la présidente Bron a dû intervenir
pour ramener le calme face au cri des
députés rien de tout cela au Palais du
Luxembourg le président du Sénat
gerérard Larcher a souhaité la bienvenue
à Gabriel Atal le Premier ministre qui a
ensuite dressé un véritable un véritable
éloge du travail du Sénat dans ce qui
ressemblait un peu à une opération
séduction Monsieur le Premier Ministre
au nom du Sénat tout entier je tiens à
nouveau à vous féliciter pour votre
nomination et à vous souhaiter la
bienvenue au sein de notre assemblée
dans vos nouvelles fonction je forme
donc le vœux monsieur le Premier
ministre que soyez attentif au Sénat
j'ai un très grand respect et même je le
dis une très grande admiration pour le
travail qui est mené ici au Sénat j'ai
toujours été je le crois très à l'écoute
de ce qui était porté par les sénatrices
et par les sénateurs du fait de
l'expérience qui est la vôtre de la
représentativité qui est la vôtre de nos
territoires dans leur très grande
diversité et Samia ça veut pas pour
autant dire que les sénatrices et les
sénateurs se sont montés plus tendre que
les députés avec le gouvernement non pas
pas forcément il y a eu quelques
échanges musclés bien sûr quand même
c'est Cécile cuckerman qui a ouvert le
bal la présidente du groupe communiste a
interpellé le Premier ministre pour
l'encourager à demander un vote de
confiance au parlementaires inutile lui
a répondu Gabriel hatal regardez
Emmanuel Macron prend tout en main des
rencontres de Saint-Denis jusqu'à hier
lors de sa conférence de politique
générale mais il n'est pas responsable
devant le Parlement vous devez donc
Monsieur le Premier Ministre demander un
vote de confiance à l'Assemblée
nationale comme l'indique l'article 49-1
de la Constitution est-ce qu'il y a une
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée nationale
non nous le savons est-ce qu'il y a
besoin d'un vote pour le démontrer non
je ne crois pas non plus est-ce qu'il y
a des Français qui se lèvent le matin en
se demandant est-ce qu'il y aura ou pas
un vote sur la déclaration de politique
générale du Premier ministre je ne crois
pas non plus est-ce que Gabriel Attal a
raison Éric Revel de refuser ce vote de
confiance devant le
bah euh il le le Premier ministre a bien
résumé les choses il y a il y a pas il y
a qu'une majorité relative euh pour son
camp donc il prend le risque de se faire
accrocher si il engage la confiance de
son gouvernement après son discours de
de de politique générale qui doit
intervenir le 30 janvier euh voilà c'est
risques mais en même temps c'est pas la
première fois que ça se passe c'est
quand même c'est quand même un sujet si
vous voulez c'est quand même un sujet
euh alors je pense que une partie de la
gauche ou de l'extrême gauche je
déposera sans doute une motion de
censure hein c'est ce qu'ont annoncé les
représentants de LFI je crois et toute
la gauche Olivier fort hier nous disait
qu' Sass c'est une façon de se
compter il démarre pas sur les chapeaux
de roues en réalité Gabriel Atal hein
c'est pas si simple que ça il y a eu
l'effet waouou et je crains qu'ilelle l'
fa assez rapidement pit pourquoi parce
que euh j'ai pas tout à fait compris
qu'elle était le le cap du président de
la République lors cette conférence de
presse qui n'en finissait plus bon on
voit restauration de l'autorité les
école les cours de théâtre bon tout ça
était donc en fait il il avance pas sur
un sur un sur un un liad rose en fait
Gabriel Atal hein c'est c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué bon il a des difficultés
dans son gouvernement qu'on connaît
notamment avec la ministre de
l'Éducation avec la nomination de Rachid
Alati bon voilà il va falloir qu'il
passe des visites de terrain à l'action
il va falloir que le premier ministre
passe du Premier ministre des
diagnostics et des intentions à des
actions qui vont bah redonner du pouvoir
d'achat au français la première priorité
des Français aujourd'hui c'est c'est le
pouvoir d'achat c'est le pouvoir d'achat
et puis la première mesure qu'ils
viennent de prendre entre guillemets en
pleine figure c'est la restauration
d'une taxe sur la facture l'lectricité
puisque bah ça va à partir du 1er
février ça lour dire 10 % c'est ça quand
même la réalité donc c'est pas si simple
que ça donc engager la responsabilité de
son gouvernement bah c'est prendre un
risque bon ben il refuse de prendre ce
risque bon don acte ouais est-ce que on
va revenir vous avez dit beaucoup de
choses on va renir tout ça sur le le le
vote de confiance est-ce qu'il a raison
Gabriel hatal lui qui ventait l'audace
de sa nomination à matigon et est-ce
qu'il prend tant que c'est un risque
alors que éic siouti dit qu'il votera ni
défiance ni confiance non mais il a
raison il a bien résumer le truc en fait
voilà il y a pas de majorité à
l'Assemblée c'est c'est c'est c'est pour
la même raison qu'Élisabeth Bor n'avait
pas sollicité de de vote de confiance en
fait ça c'est le vote de confiance
permettrait aux oppositions de faire un
coup politique de mettre le gouvernement
en difficulté comme comme ça s'était
passé pour la loi immigration avec la
motion de de rejet par exemple mais on
est dans de l'ordre du coup politique
est-ce que cette assemblée
aujourdhuceelle a des chances de passer
il a eu une vingtaine de motions de
censure aucune n pas alors non non par
contre la motion de censure non pas du
tout moi je je je je parle du vote de
confiance est-ce est-ce qu'il peut le
perdre bah oui c'est possible bien sûr
donc c'est pas la peine de se mettre
dans une dans une dans une position ça
servirait à rien en fait donc il l'a
bien résumé ils ont pas la majorité
absolu à l'Assemblée ça sert à rien
d'aller à ce à ce à ce vote ça permettre
aux oppositions de faire un un un coup
politique quel intérêt parce que en
réalité je vous rappelle que cette
assemblée elle n'a pas l'intention de de
de d'aller jusqu'au bout du bout et
créer un chaos qui qui conduirait une
une dissolution sinon il l'aurait déjà
fait depuis longtemps donc donc voilà on
est dans une espèce de de de de jeu
politique moi je vois autre chose
c'est-à-dire que je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec l'idée la la la le le côté
le risque de passer du côté wa au côté
au côté cheit euh je trouve qu'il y a un
Paris dans cette dans dans dans dans les
choix qui ont été faits par El Macron et
c'est un triptique prendre un un premier
ministre particulièrement dynamique
volontariste très jeune un un vrai
gouvernement resserré ça pour le coup ça
fait 20 ans que tout le monde dit je
vais faire un gouvernement resserré
personne le fait là pour une fois c'est
le cas avec le côté équipe de choc
commando 15 de France que sais-je
jusqu'à la deème vague parce qu'il y une
deè vue qui AR voilà oui mais bon même
s'il y a une dizaine ou une douzaine de
minist délégué et de secrétaire d'État
en plus on restera en dessous de ce qui
s'est fait ces dernières années quoi je
veux dire à chaque fois on avait des
gouvernements quand vous prenz
l'ensemble de l'équipe il y avait plus
de 40 personnes 42 43 45 donc là si
c'est une trentaine ça sera quand même
nement moins mais le 3è le trème étage
de la fusée c'était la fameuse adresse
du président de la République à la
nation ce qu'il a fait à l'élysé mardi
et je pense que
l'exercice les trois devaient se
compléter pour relancer ouvrir une
nouvelle phase du quinquena et j'ai pas
compris le le choix de la conférence de
presse pour cet exercice là parce que je
trouve que à l'arrivée ce qui en ressort
c'est quand même une impression de
grande confusion d'abord c'est un truc
qui est fait pour la télévision qui est
très parisianoparisien et moi je
comprends que Gabriel Atal arrive au
Sénat et qui et qu'il est plein de Modou
parce que le grand absent de cette de
cet exercice c'était les territoires je
veux dire on a pas parlé du tout
quasiment pas il il y a eu une incise
sur les déserts médicaux le reste zéro
rien et une des difficultés que va avoir
ce gouvernement c'est de réussir à
convaincre les Français que c'est pas un
gouvernement qui est composé de gens qui
vivent dans le 6e le 7e le 8e et le 16e
arrondissement de Paris parce que pour
l'essentiel c'est ça aujourd'hui donc
faire des déplacements et cetera un peu
partout super mais il va falloir aussi
va falloir aussi s'engager sur des
choses un petit peu plus fortes à mon
avis parce que là le le il y a un risque
aussi d'un de que l'habituel procès en
déconnexion se développe de manière
assez assez féroce dans les dans les
dans les temps qui viennent c'est aussi
ce que vous retenez de cette conférence
de presse éc Revel une forme de
déconnexion est-ce qu'il a vraiment
répondu aux préoccupations des Français
je pense que lui il en est persuadé le
président de la République les Français
le sont un peu moins j'imagine mais là
aussi je j'ai oui j'ai du mal à
comprendre si vous voulez on nous
explique pendant des jours et des jours
que le Président de la République va
parler de la nation alors on se dit
c'est un discours type Ernest Renant
1882 voyez qu'est-ce qu'une nation on se
dit le président de la République va
rejeter les bases de la nation française
peut-être en définissant de nouveaux
repères et là on a une espèce de
monologue euh
avec des
questions qui sont banalisées en fait on
le sait qu'on sait comment ça fonctionne
et je pense pas du tout qu'il a répondu
à l'exercice et alors il y a pire pour
moi parce que vous disiez mais mais
pourquoi est-ce qu'il a décidé de faire
une conférence de presse en fait euh
quand vous regardez quelques
indiscrétion quand vous lisez quelques
papiers vous apercevez que on lui avait
proposé au chef de l'État pour cette
conférence de presse d'être derrière un
pupitre ou bien d'être derrière un
bureau et il a dit non on va prendre un
bureau il faut faire gaulien il faut
faire gaulien rapporté par le monde
cette petite anecdote très intéressante
et alors là on est en pleine confusion
de communication parce que à la fois
vous nommez le plus jeune premier
ministre de la 5e République et vous
essayez de de titiller l'inconscient
collective du peuple français du côté du
général de Gaulle donc vous êtes à la
fois dans la start-up nation et dans la
France d'entants voyez et cette espèce
de de mélange des genenses fait même
s'il est brillant à l'oral le président
de la République il a pas besoin de nous
le démontrer on le sait il il a réussi
les il a passé des des euros tout va
bien mais concrètement est-ce que les
Français ont l'impression que ce grand
discours de la nation les grands
problèmes économiques qu'ils ont ont
trouvé des débuts de solution depuis
l'intervention du chef de l'État je
pense qu'il y a des médias qui vont
faire des sondages hein sur quel thème
vous vous a-t-il le plus convaincu bah
on va voir mais mais enfin à mon à mon
sens on est resté un peu et puis la
longueur de l'exercice mais attendez
avec une audience qui était pas
exceptionnelle hein euh voilà qui était
un peu au milieu de l'étiage de ce que
le président de la République fait
d'habitude lorsqu'il s'adresse aux
Français à vouloir trop communiquer en
fait on tu la communité donc il a raté
son exercice je pense qu'il a raté son
exercice pour vous aussi vous êtes aussi
s ver Stéphan exercice raté moi je pense
que c'est pas le bon forat mais euh mais
voilà tout a été dit et puis euh bon
après euh on verra l'usage alors
justement on va voir ce qu'en pensent
les républicains et notamment le patron
du groupe LR à l'Assemblée nationale
Olivier marlex il était ce matin
l'invité de la matinale de seus
cette intervention du président de la
République elle était un peu un peu
étonnante on attendait on nous avait
annoncé que le Président de la
République allait fixer un cap moi j'ai
tout entendu sauf un sauf un cap j'ai vu
un président de la républque qui partait
tous
aimut qui qui était en quelque sorte
ministre de tout qui se noyait dans le
détail ministre de tout président de
rien voilà le problème du président de
la République c'est c'est pas les mots
ce sont les faits ce sont les actes ils
ne sont pas au rendez-vous on a un
président de la République qui dans
cette conférence de presse à a dénoncé
les problèmes qu'il a lui-même créé
quand il parle de de la France de
l'angle mort en parlant des des classes
moyennes enfin pardon qui qui a depuis 7
ans plus les 5 ans où il était au
manettees auprès de François Holland a
entretenu cette politique ministre de
tout président de rien dit Olivier
marlex s on sent que Olivier marlex
avait avait préparé la punchline en
amont hein mais elle est bonne oui oui
oui alors alors ou alors président de
rien bon il est dans l'opposition et
dans son rôle j'iraai pas jusque- là
mais ministre de tout oui moi ce qui
m'avait frappé il y a y a il y a
quelques mois L d'une intervention
nouvelle du président de la République
il avait été jusqu'à dire voyez un
président de la République ne devrait
pas s'occuper de ça il avait été jusqu'à
dire il faut créer je m souvien très
bien vous pourrez vérifier une filière
de pompe à chaleur en France mais quand
vous êtes président de la République
pardonnez-moi mais est-ce que c'est de
votre niveau de même si c'est un sujet
mais le président de la République doit
pas s'exprimer sur la construction d'une
filière de pompe à chaleur là sa
première annonce était de réguler le
temps d'écran chez les enfants est-ce
que ça c'est oui non mais voilà alors
oui il laisse très peu de place voilà
tout le monde s'occupe de l'éducation
nationale vous avez vu madame Macron
s'occupe de l'éducation nationale le
Premier ministre vousous explique que
c'est de nouveau sa priorité et puis
madame oua casterra entre les Jeux
Olympiques et le sport va aussi
s'occuper un peu c'est voilà donc tout
ça est quand même pardonnez-moi mais
largement confus et encore une fois
qu'est-ce que ça change au quotidien des
Français pour ceux qui ont suivi qui ont
suivi les annonces du président de la
République d'ailleurs dans le domaine
économique la plupart des annonces qui
ont été fait entre guillemets par le
président était déjà connu depuis des
semaines des semaines des semaines des
semaines par exemple sur les 2 milliards
d'euros d'impôt de baisse pour les
classes moyennes bon il a précisé que ça
sera à partir de 2025 mais le reste on
le savait puis pardonnez-moi le mot de
de France de de l'angle mort mais c'est
terrifiant comme comme formule là il
parle des gens qui sont les moins aisés
les classes moyennes inférieur enfin les
classes moyenes il dit il dit c c'est
celles qui ont trop pour recevoir des
aides et cell qui ça les Français le
vivent c'est-à-dire que vous avez des
gens les classes moyennes c'est
2200 un peu moins de 4000 € par mois à
deux évidemment que ces classes moyennes
gagnent trop pour bénéficier de d'aide
sociale mais appelez ça la France de
l'angle mortortun monsieur le Président
vous nous avez habitu à mieux ouais vous
au niveau des formules pour pour vous là
ça a pas parleré au français cette
France de l'anglemt ces Français qui se
sonent pas représenté aujourd'hui
Stéphane alors je suis pas sûr que
l'expression passe passe bien enfin
j'avoue que je meis pas posé la question
mais je pense que le sujet le sujet est
bon et le le le le ce
enfin ce s'adresser à effectivement
cette France qui travaille qui vit dans
la peur du déclassement qui voit son
niveau de vie se se dégrader du fait de
l'inflation et
cetera là je pense que pour Gabriel Atal
avant même qu'il soit qu'il soit désigné
Premier ministre c'était clairement un
un comment dire un sujet clé notamment
dans la perspective de l'élection
présidentielle de 2027 il en a
d'ailleurs parlé dans sa passation de
pouvoir lors de ses premiers
déplacements et alors il a pas dit
France de langl mort il s'est adressé à
cette classe moyen fr la France de
l'angle mort je pense que ça ça parle à
personne effectivement l'expression mal
droite mais ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que et c'est pas un truc qui sort
du chapeau Gabriel Atal c'est ça fait ça
fait quand même un petit moment qu'il a
ça dans le dans le collimateur qu'il y
travaille moi ce que je vois c'est autre
chose c'est-à-dire que je pense que le
positionnement est bon je pense que la
volonté est bonne je pense que ce
gouvernement a envie de faire plein de
choses c'est super mais je le risque
c'est que on s'installe dans une espèce
de logique du coup médiatique permanent
de la com à outrance et et le le le vrai
risque c'est que c'est que c'est que
cette équipe perde tout le monde assez
rapidement en faisant des sauts de puces
en ouvrant des des feux des chantiers et
cetera c'est très bien mais mais mais le
risque c'est l'éparpillement la
dispersion et qu'on y comprenne plus
rien c'estd qu'effectivement ce que ce
qui était attendu de de laallocution
présidentielle c'était comme l'a dit
Olivier marlex là dans l'extrait que
vous avvez montré c'est qu' fixe un cap
c'était c'était ce que tout le monde
attendait et le ce qui s'est passé mardi
c'est pas ça je veux dire c'était c'est
pas c'est pas clair et à un
moment je je je je je pense qu'ils
onuraiit intérêt à se recentrer sur un
deux ou trois grands thèmes et qu'ils
avancent très concrètement dans les 3
ans et demi qui restent jusqu'à la fin
du quinena qu's obtiennent des résultats
parce que c'est sur les résultats que le
que la que la que la présidence
d'Emmanuel Macron va être va être jugée
pas sur des promesses on a entendu la
réaction d'Olivier marlex cette
conférence de presse il en a aussi
beaucoup été question hier Samia lors de
la séance de question d'actualité au
Gouvernement oui les les réserves qui
ont été exprimées sur ce plateau ou par
Olivier marlex ont été partagés hier par
les sénatrices et les sénateurs on l'a
dit cette conférence de presse a été
très longue 2h30 et c'est un exercice
qui a donc été très critiqué par la
gauche Patrick canner le président du
groupe social Sénat a dénoncé hier un
exercice je cite d'autosatisfaction
présidentielle alors Gabriel hatal a
pris la défense du président et pour lui
la meilleure défense c'est l'attaque une
attaque précisément dirigée contre son
ancienne famille socialiste regardez
dans un exercice assumé
d'autosatisfaction le président Macron
hier m'a rassuré notre pays va bien
l'ascenseur social fonctionne et nos
services publics ont les moyens de
remplir leur mission j'ai sans doute été
car pour moi la réalité était tout autre
dans ma réalité l'école publique est
fragilisée par des professeurs non
remplacés desabusés l'hôpital public
s'effondre je suis conscient que les
Français attendent évidemment beaucoup
en matière de santé d'accès aux soins et
d'hôpital et je le dis monsieur le
Président canner c'est su de tous j'ai
été membre du Parti socialiste j'ai
travaillé auprès de la ministre des
Affaires sociales et de la santé
monsieur le Président canner je le dis
les budgets et l'investissement qui ont
été dédiés à l'hôpital public depuis
2017 à travers le segéure de la santé
mais pas seulement on en aurait rêvé
dans les précédentes majorités on en
aurait rêvé dans les précédentes
majorités il est audible ce discours
auprès des Français Stéphan en gros
depuis qu' Emmanuel Macron ont fait ce
que la gauche et la droite n'ont pas
fait avant
bah je crois que enfin excuse-moi mais
je pense que ce que les gens voient
surtout c'est qu'il le faut 6 mois pour
avoir un rendez-vous avec un dermato
voilà donc après vous pouvez vous pouvez
développer tout ce que vous voulez comme
discours concrètement dans la vie dans
dans nos vies quotidiennes qu'est-ce qui
change ou qu'est-ce qui change pas et en
fait c'est le jour où les les les le les
les politiques qui ont été misise en
place porteront leur fruit et que ça se
verra dans votre vie quotidienne que que
les que que qu'il y aura il y aura
peut-être une enfin voilà que le le la
façon dont on appréhendera ce qui a été
ce qui a été fait se se concrétisera
pour l'instant ça reste que des mots en
fait ouais ce que ce que dit Gabriel
Atal est vrai mais encore une fois il y
a une inertiie un temps un temps un
temps long qui qui qui les desserent
parce que injecter de l'argent des
moyens et cetera redonner c'est
formidable mais mais mais par manque de
résultat tangible c'est ça bah regardez
toute la toute tout le discours sur le
numérus closusus et cetera c'est super
mais quand vous mettez fin au numérus
closusus il faut 10 ans pour avoir des
effets concrets sur le terrain donc et
moi je pense que tout ça sera audible
pour les citoyens quand ils en verront
les effets réels dans leur quotidien
pour l'instant on y est pas sur plein
plein de sujets la la réponse Gabriel
Attal m'amuse beaucoup parce qu'en fait
il dément pas les propos de Christophe
canner qui commence par dire
le l'autosatisfaction à tous les niveaux
mais pardonnez-moi la réponse de Gabriel
Atal c'est pour dire mais on a tout bien
fait depuis 2017 dans l'hôpital public
d'ailleurs tout va bien voyez en fait
donc il donne il donne raison au
président canner et puis pardonnez-moi
bien sûr qu'il y a eu un effort de fait
dans l'hôpital public mais qui n'est pas
suffisant donc dire aux Français que les
choses seraient pirees si ce
gouvernement ou cette majorité qui
n'était pas relative à l'époque depuis
2017 n'avait pas investi autant dans les
services publics mais les Français c'est
pas du tout ce qu'ils constatent il y a
des morts aux urgences il y a des gens
qui attendent des heures et des heures
et des heures on avait le meilleur
système de santé alors on disait du
monde bon enfin en tout cas on avait là
on a l'impression que tout ça ne
fonctionne mal et puis ce qui ce qui met
en colère je pense les Français quel que
soit leur leur appartenance politique
c'est que dans ce pays ils ont le
sentiment et c'est pas qu'un sentiment
voyez il payent beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'impôts et il voit
les services publics beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup se dégrader et ils se
disent mais que se
passe-t-il alors le discours de Monsieur
hatal avec sa fraîcheur son dynamisme
son talent je pense qu' il passe pas du
tout parce que sur le terrain c'est pas
ce que les gens constatent du tout sur
le terrain ils constatent que les
urgences sont engorgées qu'effectivement
il faut attendre des mois et des mois
pour avoir un rendez-vous avec un
spécialiste et cette France là de
l'angle mort comme dit le président de
la République c'est la France qui
souffre et souvent en silence jusqu'au
moment 2019 où il y a eu le mouvement
des gilets jaunes ouais est-ce que c'est
aussi la la France qui se tourne vers
Marine Le
Pen alors oui c'est intéressant parce
que en fait il y a eu a il y a il y a un
Gliss il y a un long glissement il a eu
un long glissement progressif notamment
de la d'une partie des classes moyennes
vers vers vers le rassemblement national
on le voit on le voit de scrutin en
scrutin c'est un des enjeux c'est un des
enjeux forts de ces de ces européennes
on sait que le le rassemblement national
fait la course en tête dans les sondages
sur à quoi on assiste aussi en terme de
remanement nouveau Premier ministre et
cetera l'idée qui consiste à insuffler
une une dynamique elle est là aussi pour
sauver les meubles c'estàdire que
on on sait à peu près sûr
que je peux pas dire que le scrutin est
joué c'est pas vrai mais il est il est
très possible que que que que le Bor il
est très probable que le rassemblé
nationale arrive en tête au mois de juin
et en fait ce qui essae la volonté ce
qui essaie de faire le le gouvernement
l'exécutif la majorité présidentielle
c'est de réduire l'écart au minimum
c'est ce qu'avait réussi à faire
Renaissance la République en marche à
l'époque en 2019 où en réalité le
rassemblement national avait remporté
les élections européennes mais d'un
nombre de voix qui était pas qui était
qui était enfin l'écart était assez
faible qui fait qu'à l'arrivée
Renaissance et le rassemblement national
avait eu le même nombre de députés
envoyés au Parlement européen et ce qui
était une défaite avait pu être présenté
comme une victoire et je je je Gabri moi
j'ai le sentiment qu'ils essayent de
faire la même chose il peut atteindre
cette objectif Gabriel Attal Erric Revel
ça paraît quand même complexe sur
l'électorat du assemble nationale je
dirais qu'il y a des il y a des
conditions historiques qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé il y a des éléments
historiques puis il y a des éléments
conjoncturel les éléments historiques
c'est pardonnez-moi mais c'est de
souvenir que le Parti communiste par
exemple français a abandonné le concept
de la lutte du prolétariat qui faisait
que la classe ouvrière votait largement
pour lui de l'instant avit où où il y a
eu cet abandon j'allais dire politique
bah la classe ouvrière s'est senti un
peu orpheline historiquement la
publication par le sing Tang socialiste
Terranova d'une note expliquant que les
classes moyennes était plus vraiment
l'objectif de la gauche et bien le
rassemblement national a capté cet
électorat autour de deux thèmes qu'on n
pas vu venir ou que certains ont vu
venir mais ces thèmes était enfin le
premier était souvent dénoncé comme
étant l'élément d'un fascisme d'une
extrême droite c'était la question de
l'immigration bon le rassemblement
national avec les les outrages les
outran s'en est emparé puis la deuxième
question c'est celle du pouvoir d'achat
je le disais c'est la première
préoccupation des Français mais qui a
fait campagne présidentielle sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat hasard ou
nécessité bah c'est Marine Le Pen donc
si vous voulez d'une certaine manière
elle est dans le bon timing bien
positionnée normalisé également
politiquement par l'émergence d'éc
Zémour qui a capté à lui les thèmes les
plus extrêmes euh oui elle est pas au
pouvoir mais je pense que beaucoup
réfléchissent à cette éventualité quand
même ouais ça veut dire que dans sa
tirade antirn antifront national
puisqu'il veut continuer à l'appeler
comme ça Emmanuel Macron qu'il a faite
mardi il a dénoncé le parti du mensonge
le parti de l'appauvrissement collectif
et il dit qu'il faut tout faire pour
donner aux gens de ne plus donner de
raison aux gens en tout cas de voter
rassemblement national est-ce qu'il y
parvient il a cité la loi immigration
lui par exemple mais c'est ce qu'il
avait c'est ce qu'il avait déclaré euh
c'est ce qu'il avait déclaré lors de ce
ces le le les soir les soirs quand il aé
de ses victoires présidentielles à deux
reprises c'est ça je je ferai en sorte
que vous n'ayez plus de raison de de de
de voter pour le rassemement national
ben sauf que concrètement c'est pas ce
qui se passe alors après vous avez une
conjoncture et cetera mais effectivement
la question du pouvoir d'achat
l'inflation fait que on est dans une on
est dans un dans une dans une période où
c'est ces préoccupations là ces
problématiques là elles sont accrues
elles sont elles sont elles sont elles
sont elles deviennent cruciales je veux
dire voilà il y a du coup vous avez vous
avez un discours qui percolle d'autant
plus facilement et ce qui explique aussi
la volonté d'un Gabriel hatal ou d'un
Emmanuel Macron de se positionner et de
de de de parler à nouveau aux classes
aux classes moyenne qui qui voit glisser
dans le dans le temps mais encore une
fois ça se passe au-delà des mots il
faut aussi qu'il a des résultats
concrets pour convaincre les gens qu'il
se passe quelque chose et pour résultat
des résultats comme comm
Gabri on va terminer en regardant ce qu'
de la presse régionale ce matin C avec
[Musique]
Samia
et Samia c'est bien sûr la neige qui
fait la une des quotidiens dans le Nord
ce matin oui attention ça glisse
prévient la voie du Nord prudence
conseille aussi le Courrier Picard il
est tombé jusqu'à 10 cm de neige dans
les Haut- de France de quoi perturber la
circulation des bus des trains des
automobilistes bref c'est la galère
résume Nord éclair c'est la première
grande pagaille hivernale aussi dans
l'Est raconte ce matin le républicain la
Laurin puisque la laorine est elle aussi
touchée par des chutes de neige et des
pluies verglçantes et alors que fr
s'installe des milliers de logements
restent vide c'est ce que regrette la
Marseillaise plus de 155000 logements
sont vacants dans la région Provence
chiffre le journal ça veut dire un
logement sur 13 certaines villes sont
plus touchées que d'autres Arles Avignon
ou encore Carpentra où une femme sans
domicile fixe est morte de froid le 9
janvier rapporte La Marseillaise le
journal qui rappelle la proposition de
loi déposé la semaine dernière par le
sénateur communiste Yann brossa
réquisitionner les logements vides on va
encore l'idée de l'uniforme à l'école
fait son chemin dans le sud de lîle oui
la ville de bonifatio est prête à
l'expérimenter dès la rentrée 2024 pour
les 210 élèves de l'école primaire le
maire Jean-Charles orsouch va organiser
une consultation des parents qui pour
l'instant se montre plutôt favorable à
l'idée pour gommer les inégalités disent
certains et puis aussi disent d'autres
de manière peut-être un peu plus honnête
pour gagner du temps le matin en évitant
un conflit avec leur progéniture sur le
choix de la tenue du jour allez on
termine dans les Pays de la Loire on
recrute des volontaires ren
des renifleurs pour l'estuaire c'est la
Une de presse auocéan ce matin RPI de la
Loire à recruté 15 sentinelles Olfactiv
15 personnes qui vont être formées à
reconnaître et identifier les mauvaises
odeurs ces bénévoles seront donc chargés
de renifler quotidiennement pour mieux
localiser les odeurs gênantes issues des
industries installées le long de
l'esuire de la Loire ce qui devrait
permettre à terme de réduire les
nuisances c'est original la Une de
wouest France Stéphane c'est le congé de
naissance à quoi faut-il s'attendre à
lire dans votre journal voilà on invite
nos lecteurs nos téléspectateurs à lire
West France à lire l'hémicycle aussi
refaire nation c'est à la Une de
l'hémicycleou refire nation avec je vous
le conseille enfin je vous la conseille
une très bonne interview croisée alors
je dis pas ça parce que j'ai faite mais
je trouve ça marrant parce que on a fait
discuter débatre place du Colonel Fabien
au siège du Parti communiste Fabien
Roussel et Patrick Martin le nouveau
patron du meddeef qui est venu place du
Colonel Fabien voilà donc on aborde
beaucoup DESS et puis il nous a fait
visiter Fabien Roussel l'intégralité de
place du CONEL Fabien après l'interview
dans l'émicyclle un mot de votre livre
le tirailleur inconnu voilà une histoire
extraordinaire d'un d'un tirailleur qui
est enterré à l'île de Ray en fait il
n'a jamais mis le pied en France qui est
mort pour la France en fait il est monté
sur un bateau comme 400 autres
tirailleurs le Sequana qui était coulé
au large de l'îedieu et son corps est
venu s'échouer sur une plage coardaise
sur l'île doré et je raconte le destin
fabuleux de ce tirailleur merci éc Revel
merci beaucoup merci Stéphane Vernet
d'être resté avec nous merci Samien
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
prochain rendez-vous 18h sens public et
nous on se retrouve demain très bonne
journée